you know people love our studio they
love the IDE they love our pro products
and it's been really tough working
through the Rebrand of our studio
worrying that our users would get the
message that like we don't believe in
our anymore and that's absolutely not
the case like posit is not about like
pivoting from art of python it's about
broadening and embracing the python
Community as well as the our community
so I think that that's my big message
for the our community is like we still
100 believe in our I think it is a just
a fantastic environment for doing
interactive data science and we're going
to continue to invest in it but what I
hope we can bring to the python
ecosystem is some of the sort of like
beautiful end-to-end orchestration that
we've provided the our community with
things just work and I think that is you
know very you know broadly what we want
with all of our Open Source Products
with all of our pro products that you
try something and it just works first
time and and that that's just such a
joyful experience
[Music]